le 22 mars 2016 à bruxelles il ya une
série d'attentats qui touche la ville de
à l'aéroport et le troisième dans une
rame de métro le bilan définitif fera 32
morts et 342 blessés
c'est sale vous allez être rapidement
être suspecté d'avoir été un des
terroristes le fameux homme au chapeau
qui s'est échappé que la police cherche
à tout prix à retrouver regardez cette
vidéo faite par les enquêteurs après le
drame regarde dans le cadre de l enquête
sur l'attentât commis à l'aéroport de
bruxelles le 22 mars 2016 les services
de police cherchent à retracer le chemin
de l'auteur qui a pris la fuite
une fois les bombes explosaient à 7h58
l'homme à la veste claire et au chapeau
est sorti du bâtiment
il est passé devant le sheraton et à
tourner à droite pour emprunter le
parking et sortir du site de l'aéroport
il a alors traversé à pied la commune de
zaventem tout en se débarrassant de sa
veste claire la chemise du fuyard semble
être de couleur bleu clair il pourrait
également un pantalon foncés et des
chaussures brune avec de larges semelle
blanche alors fait ça chez vous allez
donc être soupçonnée d'être cet homme au
chapeau
comment vous apprenez vous êtes
soupçonné
je suis arrêté tout simplement direct
comment ça s'est passé viennent chez
vous alors je suis donc ces deux jours
après les attentats de bruxelles
d'accord je suis chez moi à la maison
j'ai un ami qui me propose d'aller
chercher un pote à frère à lui donc à
l'aéroport je devais aller chercher
parce que les avions ont été déroutés
vers liège avait plus d'avion qui
descendait à bruxelles d'accord donc du
coup je l'accompagnerai j'ai rien à
faire donc ok je te suis on monte dans
la voiture on prend la route
indeed qui prend sa soeur également pour
l'emmener faire des cours du soir
et là on est pris en filature par la
police on le savait pas et on arrive
devant une déviation il ya une justice
et une déviation parce que on m'a
demandé qu'est ce que je faisais devant
le palais de justice on passe devant pas
de justice pas ce qui est une déviation
il y avait des travaux dans les tunnels
ont tout simplement
c'est pour ça que je me retrouve un car
devant le palais de justice et là d'un
coup une voiture banalisée démarque par
la gauche
une autre en cercle et là je vois des
des flics à ce moment là je n'ai pas que
c'était police des policiers mais des
hommes armés qui sortent du gros calibre
et qui mettent leurs cagoules
je vois des vêtements couleur kaki qu ça
me faisait penser à des militaires pas
des militaires
et là je n'ai pas le temps de réaliser
ça va mais ça va très vite en fait donc
pas le temps de voir les brassards et
c'est moi je me suis content j'ai vu une
chose c'est un policier en face de moi
avec une mitraillette et aucun vraiment
un fusil d'assaut qui me faisait et qui
me qui tremblaient et et moi je suis là
et un silence de mort bien sûr je n'ai
et je me dis c'est bon c'est la fin je
veux mourir en fait directement je me
dis c'est fini quoi le regard de ce mec
je n'oublierai jamais et il tremblait et
donc je souffrais tellement me lever vos
mains vous mélangez un réflexe dans la
voiture on sait pas ce qui se passe
y'a silence de mort donc du coup à
partir de ce moment-là lui même mon pote
il dit ça c'est des flics les flammes à
ils sont en train de paranoïa et donc
instantanément j'ai levé les mains la
soeur de mon pote elle était tétanisé
elles arrivaient pas et on lui dit mais
lève tes mains et elle était là elle
n'arrivait pas et du coup ça va très
vite mon pote
il lui tape dans la vitre à gauche ils
le font et extraire par la vitre moi on
me demande de sortir par la gauche
j'essaye de sortir et un mec à droite
qui me dit tu bouges pas une balle dans
la tête une bouge pas et donc du coup je
suis resté là jeudi à entendez-vous là
moi je bouge plus donc et je suis resté
comme ça ils m'ont demandé de sortir par
la droite et ce qui m'étonnait en fait
c'est que mon pote ils ont directement
attraper sa soeur ils ont directement
mises dehors et moins il y avait un il y
avait une distance comme ça de 2,3 m je
comprenais pas c'est vraiment une peur
etc bouge pas bouge pas bougent pas
assez attention chaque ne fais pas de
gestes brusques et c'est vraiment cette
situation qui est qui qui faisait que en
fait j'ai intérêt à les écouter
si je veux pas que cette balle arrive
dans ma tête quand tout simplement
c'était ça dans le coin j'étais
concentré écouter ce qu'ils disent et
fait ce qu'il faut faire
enfin réagi calmement pas de gestes et
donc je mets ma main
donc il me demande d'ouvrir la porte de
droite j'ouvre la porte de droite et là
ils disent vraiment pas de geste brusque
qui est d'abord ton pied donc je sors et
là je vois un tireur d'élite un peu plus
loin avec je vois de la lumière qui nous
tapaient dans les yeux et en fait
c'était un policier qui était avec un
tireur d'élite qui visait qui me
disaient clairement et ils sont autour
de moi et me vise avec eux leurs armes
et il ya un silence et je comprends pas
donc moi même je met les mains sur la
tête
enfin les films je les écarte les jambes
et là il me demande de mettre au sol et
ils sont toujours autour de moi avec une
distance je comprends pas je me mets au
sol tu écartes les mains des acheteurs
que vous avez une ceinture sauf que
c'est plus tard que j'ai décidé parce
que à ce moment là directement il ouvre
le coffre de la voiture et là il me
tutoie plus ils vous voient c'est
monsieur acier vous ça va bien se passer
calmez vous et je me dis mais en fait
ils disaient il n'y a pas de bombe il
n'y a pas de bombay a pas de bombe
je comprends pas et donc je retourne et
je vois le coffre et cherchent ils sont
concentrés dans le coffre de la voiture
donc à partir de ce moment là il ya une
tension comme ça qui est tombé et je
leur ai dit écoutez ici on est cool
depuis le départ donc faites en autant
fait en temps calmez vous et donc il me
demande de mettre au sol et me mettre
des bandeaux sur les yeux et on est
emmené manu militari un parent dans des
voitures
alors là si vous nous rejoignez sachez
que on a le témoignage de fait seul
c'est fou ces témoignages fois on le vit
avec lui
faysal de qui a été pris et voilà pour
l'homme au chapeau qui avait été cet
homme qui avait été suspecté d'avoir été
vous avez été suspecté d'avoir été un
des terroristes des attentats du 22 mars
2016 à bruxelles quand ils nous
racontent l'histoire on est on est
dedans donc là vous êtes tranquillement
en train d'aller à l'aéroport avec votre
pote
voilà là donc vous vous faites arrêter
déjà une scène la scène à la durée qu'on
même temps cette scène autour de la
voiture
elle prend 2 3 minutes c'est pour vous
ça dure des heures c'est juste vous avez
eu du mal à quoi vous avez peur de
mourir non c'est clair c'est fini en
fait moi je me dis et je comprends pas
ce qui se passe et vous dites je vais
mourir je ne sais pas pourquoi oui et
j'ai pas parce que plusieurs formats
l'emea vous réalisez qu'il y avait des
attentats il ya deux jours non
médicalisés pas moi moi je te merde en
plus en plus à des attentats d'il ya
deux jours on s'imagine dans quel état
vous êtes et dans quel état de stress de
nerfs vous êtes tous dans la voiture et
là vous voyez des gars cagoulés qui vous
en cercle et qui bouge charge et et
c'est des phrases dont la saab on l'a eu
c'est ça je crois qu est-ce que c'est
bon ton pote on l'a eue à liège alors
qui revient de syrie etc
donc est ce que je vois pas ce que
j'avais les yeux bandés dans la voiture
un chien je vois leur a en fait des bals
des balles qui tombe clairement et non
mais il était en train de décharger
leurs armes et tué jeudi mais attendez
vos armées s'étaient chargés là alors
été remise
va assumer merde il y avait une balle
enclenché dans le truc il nous fit
devait faire qu'un geste et s'était
terminé maintenant mais heureusement que
n'avait pas fait un mauvais geste mal un
geste qui aurait été mal pris et il a
parce que la passe avant d'arriver au
sérieux une injonction moi c'est ça
c'est le silence de mort et c'est mon
pote qui me dit lève tes mains et quand
je sors c'est moi qui prend l'initiative
eux ils sont un peu ils sont comme ça
avant ses pas et c'est à partir du
moment où le coffre s'ouvre que la
tension diminue à leur niveau je vois
les balles dans la voiture quand je suis
transféré et là bon je vois rec quand on
enlève les bandes au commissariat je
vois des policiers en cagoule gillet par
des militaires quoi c'est s'est alors
fait sale là vous arriver au
commissariat
parce que pour l'instant vous savez
toujours pas pourquoi vous êtes arrivé
c'est toujours pas pourquoi vous avez
vécu ça qu'est ce qui se passe à ce
moment là quand vous arrivez au
commissariat alors ça va durer des
heures
je vais pas savoir ce que c'est donc là
que vous êtes mieux cette nuit dans une
directement dans une c'est donc il ya un
couloir et je me mets dans la cellule de
droite on me demande fait une fouille au
corps cette seule dans la cellule ouais
d'accord avec mon pote je sais plus où
il est à ce moment là on me demande de
faire une france et une fouille et ils
prennent lamboley moi j'avais abonnés
faisait un petit peu froid cette année
mais la période on prend le benêt et on
me dit ça tu porte souvent ses abonnés
quand il fait froid et il prend ça il le
met dans un sac scellés et donc fouille
au corps et la transférer dans un dans
un dans une cellule et je vois plein de
flics mais pleins pleins à plat ils sont
trentaine c'est impressionnant et je me
dis mais c'est parce que vous voulez
mais vous fait une grosse erreur et
landis à hawaï clairement parce que j'ai
rien à voir là c'est impressionnant ce
que vous êtes en train de faire là mais
c'est pas moi j'ai pas pu donner corps à
ce moment là quand vous soupçonne d'être
un des auteurs des à mon père n'en sais
que c'est ce que tu as fait mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que j'ai
fait tu sais très bien ce que tu as fait
et ils sont tes potes tu veux pas parler
maintenant ça va venir
en fait c'est ça qui va se passer
pendant des heures c'est un point
d'interrogation je sais pas ce qui se
passe je leur demande qu'est ce qui se
passe mais tu sais très bien ton pote on
l'attrapé revient de syrie mon pote mais
qui ou à quoi tu sais vas-y balance tout
comme ça on va gagner du temps d'un cran
en plus comble de malchance vous
habitiez proche des lieux de l'attentât
de la station de métro
vous aviez été filmée après l'attentât
dont assez heureux c'est chose faite là
en fait rien s'ils sont contre tout
contre vous tous mais accuse clairement
et je comprends pas donc il veut ils
veulent prendre mais en tête mais
empreinte et monde d'hommes moi j'ai des
policiers des policiers qui sont venus
avec eux c'est des policiers
scientifiques qu'ils avaient des gilets
pare-balles blanc des gants de
chirurgien tout habillés en blanc et
tout et ils me demandent donc des
masques de chirurgiens et on nous
demande de mes empreintes je dis ok je
vais accepter les empreintes et après
ils mettent des trucs en plastique sur
les mains un truc qui colle tout
simplement et je dis ce qu'est ce que
c'est là qu'est ce qui nous attend pas
me faire et me disent verts c'est pour
la poudre jetée atp qu'est ce que c'est
le tatp juin c'est le truc explosif et
que c'est pas ça pour ça si vous aviez
de la poudre sur les mains ou c'est moi
je comprenais pas et je n'ai jamais peur
qu'on mette quelque chose à cech j'ai
rien à voir avec ça donc c'est parce que
après qu'ils aient quand ils ont fait
ces analyses
ils n'ont pas vu que vous n'aviez pas un
poudre que vous n'aviez pas en c'est un
truc de malade c'est que moi je
cultivais un petit peu à l'époque un
petit dixième
j'avais un petit plant de cannabis je
les fais partie mais j'avais un petit
plant de cannabis et donc du coup
j'avais un petit peu d'engrais et c'est
plus tard donc d'utiliser devant regrets
et donc plus tard dans le bureau du juge
le juge d'instruction de ma forme que je
suis positif côté atp jamais comment ça
positif c'est quoi le tpc d'explosifs et
ses régimes attendait c'est impossible
ça c'est impossible
et du coup il me dit non mais il ya du
diable en grève n'est pas manipulé de
langue anglaise jessie j plants de
cannabis ne regrettent tous les jours et
bien voilà les bombes en fait ont été
faites à base d'engrais non année ça moi
je découvre je comprends pas ce qu'est
ce que c'est fou donc ils se disent
c'est la personne assez positif j'habite
à côté positif
ôtez atp vous êtes alors si quatre jours
après les attentats vous allez donc être
arrêté deux inculpés à deux jours deux
ans inculpé pour participation aux
activités d'un groupe terroriste
assassinat terroriste et tentative
d'assassinât terroriste
là vous apprenez ça comment ça se passe
alors j il m'a fallu quatre heures donc
j'ai été arrêté à 18h30 vers 23h30 la
vérité pas demandé mon avocat je
n'arrêtais pas de demander des
informations supplémentaires avant de
revenir sur le juge d'instruction est en
fait ils sont venus et m'ont dit on va
négocier
vous voulez savoir pourquoi vous êtes là
dites nous clairement donnez-nous vos
empreintes accepté l'adn ce qu'ils
voulaient des cheveux il voulait
j'ai dit non je veux voir mon avocat
dont l'avocat est mort commence à mon
avocat et moi je me dis peut-être qu'il
est mort dans les attentats
j'en sais rien bref je veux je veux mes
droits on négocie et j'accepte tout donc
vous donner mes droits je vous donne les
empreintes je vous donne mes cheveux etc
mais d'abord je veux savoir pourquoi je
suis là il sort il négocié pendant 15
minutes avec les policiers y revient et
me dit vous êtes succédé des attentats
de bruxelles c est soupçonné d'avoir
participé aux importantes légitime et
l'agent chimique rohm en fait c'est fou
en fait beaucoup plus pour tarir et je
me dis mais c'est complètement
hallucinant parce que vous êtes en train
de vous bourrez hélas les coûts commence
et tu te fout de notre gueule on est
sérieux avec trois ans
mais vous êtes malade j'ai rien à voir
et là c'est la claque à dire des mots
riad ya plus qu il ya plus de 300
blessés il ya des 35 morts et sont là
moi j'ai vu des sacs de couchage et que
c'est que plus tard que j'ai compris que
les policiers n'ont même pas en fait
depuis les attentats il était assuré
fondant peinture et donc qu'ils avaient
une pression il fallait attraper le
dernier terrien qui avait fui en fait
c'est l'homme au chapeau un nouveau
chapeau le fugitif donc j'arrive
ensuite je parle avec mon avocat à 23h
23h30 je vais enfin savoir qu'est ce qui
se passe quand je suis à auditionner
parce qu'on me montre cette photo
la célèbre photo on voit les trois
terrorisation et donc on me dit regardez
bien cette photo elles sont là la photo
est donc là il pense que ces boîtes
clairement à droite et ils me disent
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette photo
c'est la photo des terroristes mais
regardez bien vous reconnaissez
quelqu'un sinon vraiment pas en plus
c'est flou on reconnaît presque personne
et me dit mais regardez bien à droite
c'est peut-être pas vos là j'ai quoi et
c'est là que je réalise 1 vous confondez
que ça mais ça l'arrêt vous êtes sérieux
regardez les épaules regarder le visage
mais c est lui qui m de plus que vous ou
6 centimètres est même plus un il est
même plus parce que mon avocat m'a dit
qu'il connaissait un des terroristes
l'urgence n'est fermée de 73 c ça
faisait beaucoup et on voit la carrure
les épaules moi je suis quelqu'un comme
disait mon avocat il est chétif il est
tout mais ça n'a rien à voir là pour ce
qui peut voir ça et puis c'est une photo
complètement fou ça peut être n'importe
qui vous lui mettez un chapeau des
lunettes et puis c'est bon et donc quand
je passe devant le juge d'instruction
vous allez remarquer une chose parce que
mon avocat
tous les flics qui s'était concentré il
avait complètement oublié les
associations et essentielle parce que
quand je débats
chez le juge il me dit vous vos amis
sont en morceaux et qu'est ce que ça
vous fait j'ai même si le juge ait rien
à voir mes amis c'est pas mes amis ces
terroristes ou vous bourrez et là il me
demande un peu mon itinéraire où j'ai
été comment ça se fait que tu habites à
deux pas il faut le pire c'est que le
terroriste quand il a fui de zaventem il
a marché pendant une heure et demie et
perd sa trace à 200 m chez moi c'est
clair c'est lui quoi et donc ton
itinéraire comment ça se fait qu'est ce
que tu faisais là et est ce que tu avais
quelqu'un avec chez toi c'est toi la
maison qui peut prouver ton ta présence
n'ont donc alors ils sont ils vont sur
google maps il regarde les trucs mon
avocat et là il remarque qui regarde
vers la photo il est monsieur le juge
qu est ce pour quoi ils ont une fois
c'est noir à droite une main noire des
mains libres et la gauche
là ma gauche et c'est quoi ça mais je
dis pas c'est une paire de gants ouais
ok qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la pour une
paire de gants pour quoi ils ont une
seule paire de vans fait y avait un
détonateur
donc en fait le gant dissimule un
détonateur nature les mecs se balade
pendant 30 minutes dans l'aéroport où le
tranquille avec une paire de gants comme
sam sam et de à dire en tenue militaire
presque une sorte de réflexe
pendant que celui de droite si vous
remarquez bien là pas de gants ouais et
là mon avocat maître martin se disait
martin un excellent avocat dit mais
attendez il loue chariot pasquet les
empreintes du terroriste un bien sûr et
la juge fait ça est fait je n'ai pas dit
ça non et prend son téléphone
il appelle les policiers leur demandent
où est le chariot et ils lui disent le
chariot et se place ni les charrues est
sur place et en fait il ya 300 chariot
ils sont tous étaient balancés donc ils
ont oublié ce chariot sur place et il
est resté avec la troisième bombe à
l'aéroport
et pendant ce temps là bas ils ont
oublié le chariot donc ils ont pas les
empreintes et mon aventure dima temps d
aller chercher ce chariot tout de suite
comment ça se fait qu'on a perdu plus de
4 jours avec cheyrou fayçal et là on n'a
même pas vérifié ses empreintes et moi
je me rends compte de ça mais qu'est ce
qui se passe là et il me dit le trois
ministres m'ont appelé pour moi le
ministre de l'intérieur le premier
ministre et le ministre de la justice et
demande qu'ils ne gardent même dit moi
je suis pour les droits de la défense
je vais aller sur place ces cow-boys de
policiers moi je travail sérieux c'est
le juge d'instruction
je vais aller sur place et je vais
reprendre cette affaire parce que ça
devient louche et surtout quand il lui a
demandé pourquoi vous avez refusé le
tapissage caisse
tapissage tasser la neige tombe à
rappeler tapissage c'est quand vous avez
plusieurs personnes qui sont alignés et
il ya une des personnes bien entendu qui
peut être reconnus comme étant des
sables on m'a jamais parlé de ça
d'accord j'ai dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est que jamais on m'a parlé de ça et
là l'avocat s'énerve ce qui m'y
attendais si on n'a même pas déplacé de
témoin parce que dans toute cette
histoire
en fait ils ont montré cette photo un
témoin le témoin c'est le taximan qui
transportent les trois terroristes et
qui les accompagnent et ils vous avez
reconnu lui il regarde la photo il dit
ça à 200% c'est lui ah oui il confirme à
200 % mais ils ont même pas déplacé au
commissariat c'est fou et on dit que
c'est moi qui a revu s'est refusé la
vitesse d'un certain jeudi mais non je
refuserai pas un truc comme ça et donc
le jus se rend compte de ça qu'on a même
pas convoqué le témoin sa première cape
en est donc là il me dit tu vas
retourner au commissariat j'y crois pas
trop on va vérifier je donnais mois
quelques jours je vais aller moi-même à
l'aéroport je prends cette affaire en
main et il me dit un truc de da que j'ai
pas réalisé son domaine
ml on est samedi demain donc baron je
travaille pas généralement mais je vais
faire quelques heures supplémentaires
pour vous donc je vais aller sur place
et me dise un pas être évident parce que
lundi je ne garantis pas vous êtes
libérés parce que lundi m6 les vacances
de pâques
certains de superman vous passer combien
de temps on garde à vue alors je pense
plus de 48 heures en garde à vue ça a
été très long
et d'ailleurs le juge d'instruction m'a
dit tu retournes au commissariat et si
le tapissage est négatif moi je te
libère directement alors le tapissage de
rappel pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
donc ils ont mis différentes personnes
alignées dont vous il ya une personne
c'était quoi c'était le chauffeur de
taxi c'est ça qui devait reconnaître ou
pas babineau et vous reconnaître ou pas
l'un des coupables
exactement je vais revenir là lors il se
fait ce tapis ça joue pas alors le tapis
web sur le tapissage donc en fait mon
avocat a fait une remarque plus tard me
la raconter je me suis mis au milieu en
fait et ils ont pris juste les personnes
qui étaient dans des cellules d'accord
donc arrêté normalement on doit prendre
des personnes qui doivent plus ou moins
ressembler l'un sur le tapis ça se passe
bien
or ils ont pris que les personnes qui
étaient invincibles comment je déçu j'ai
vu que j'avais pas de là c'est
maintenant que c'était des personnes
arrêtées et les personnes c'était bon
j'aime il y avait même un bleu roi pour
vous dit
et on me met au milieu enfin je me mets
au je me place au milieu et l'avocat
plus tard m'a dit quand je vous ai vu
vous mettre au milieu j'avais
confirmation que c'était pas vous à ce
moment là tu pourquoi ben c'est la place
on évite de se mettre en fait parce que
sa part à gauche et à droite
et c'est là la place de du coupable
idéal
donc comment quand moi je vous ai vus a
consciemment ou vous mettre là j'ai su
que c'était s'était pas vous en faites
et donc le tapissage ce fait il ya un
chronomètre de l'avocat me ma forme
parce que l'avocat est avec le taximan
derrière la vitre sans tain et il ya un
chronomètre là ils ont bien fait les
choses et il a reconnu en quelques
secondes
ouais c'est oui je confirme 700% que
c'est lui croire ce moment là la machine
s'emballe enfin clairement je retourne
donc le juge macule pas partir de ce
moment là je ne savais pas en fait que
mon nom était dans la presse va bien sûr
partout non est ce juste avant même le
juge d'instruction parce que quand je
suis dans la voiture et emmenée chez le
juge d'instruction les dans la voiture
je l'entend à la radio
fayçal chef ou terroristes je me dis
mais qu'est ce qui se passe et on dit
ouais mais ton nom est déjà été balancé
donc il ya eu déjà des informations qui
ont fuité ou votre famille regardent la
famille était dans une panique totale
message pour vous en parler plus tard
mais c'était de contact avec personne
donc là qu'est ce qui se passe vous êtes
inculpés qui se passe donc je retourne
au commissariat il ya eu la culture est
automatiquement confirmation du témoin
et on me demande mon adn dont on
comprend et comptons tiges on le met
sous la langue est hélas ils se trompent
de boîte je le remarque
bref c'est un détail donc je donne mon à
mon adn
le juge m'a demandé pourquoi j'avais
refusé mon adn mais c'était pour vous
rencontrer pour savoir qu'est ce qui se
passait justement jusqu'à présent
maintenant maintenant que je sais mais
je vais tout donner adn tout ce que vous
voulez et donc en cellule et là derrière
en fait les médias ont parlé de moi à ce
moment là je suis au courant de rien je
suis transféré en prison
donc on dit c'est bon mandat d'arrêt est
là quand j'arrive en prison bon déjà il
faut savoir je vous montre juste
quelques lignes tout ça c'est ça c'est
le dossier il était en néerlandais
je suis francophone je comprenais rien
de l'accusation j'aime pas ce qui se
passait et je reçois ça je rentre je
rentre en prison et je me dis mais je
comprends que dalle en fait de sa faire
donc je comprenais rien
mais ok bon du coup je regarde la
télévision et là c'est tout un truc
parce que j'ai un directeur de la prison
qui débarque et qu'il me donne ce papier
je vous lis juste une ligne ovi des
musées des moyens qui ont été mis en
oeuvre pour la paix prêtre perpétration
de ces attentats et leur sang-froid et
détermination la plus grande prudence
s'impose
et en l'absence de tout autre élément la
dangerosité est avéré pouvant menacer
l'ordre et la sécurité de
l'établissement
dans cette même idée long de
médiatisation et elle qui convient de
protéger le reste de la population
détenue de tout risque de prosélytisme
les ministres mesures de sécurité
particulières est donc là en fait il me
retire tout ce qui est moche est le
miroir les j'avais un gobelet en
plastique et me ramène une télévision et
il me dit vous êtes sur toutes les
chaînes du monde entier chez nous dans
cette prison on a le bouquet donc vous
allez vous amuser
il me ramène la télé leur loyer votre
tête partout ah ouais là quand il va
déposer latéral chez vous et ont brisé
en espagnol au russe artur hein non mais
c'est une île à ce moment là nous avons
dû par là qui a eu envie de gueuler là
j'ai envie de dire mais c'est pas moi
et en fait je vais rentrer deux parce
que dans la prison les gens d'aller les
gardiens passaient ces salles
terroristes et c'est même pareil quand
j'étais pendant les 48 heures au
commissariat
c'est yves le clapet salle terroristes
de mer tu as tué plus de trente deux
personnes on va rester ici tu vas tu
vois tu vas jamais sortir d'ici et c'est
des insultes delhommeau chapeau
assassins criminels salle djihadiste est
bref et je subis sans respect commun
dont je reste trois jours en prison
moi j'ai 48 heures en garde à vue au
commissariat et trois jours à jour en
prison donc cinq jours d'enfer enfin
comment ça se tient alors toutes les 15
5 toutes les 15 minutes ils viennent
taper à la dans la cellule et où il
ouvre une lumière flash
je dormais pas et c'était impossible de
dormir donc je veux ça c'est je regarde
la télévision j'entends mais alors tout
un truc des des spécialistes experts qui
viennent de parler dans des plateaux
pendant 20 minutes en disant par exemple
même patron de paris match le
porte-parole de paris match qui dit mais
c'est un homme avec un sang-froid une
détermination et ses îles et là j'ai en
fait je vois mon procès public donc je
suis là j'écoute
ces lanternes mais à ce moment là je
vais passer le restant de ma vie en
cellule je commence à me préparer
c'est bon je suis ici il va falloir pas
devenir fou en fait je commence à péter
un câble je commence à me dire est ce
que je suis pas les genres somnambule
comme sa main est là quand je me suis
dit ça à un moment vous êtes disciples
et moi ah ouais mais parce que je devais
temps qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que et là je commence à devenir
pété un câble parce que si je suis allé
et que j'étais pas conscient alors là tu
crains hélas je commence à péter un
câble non mais c'est pas moi je sais que
c'est pas moi je suis pas faire un truc
comme ça j'ai pas été éduqué comme ça et
donc je suis comme ça pendant les trois
jours et c'est vraiment d'apprendre une
bouche non et en fait je suis tombé sur
un directeur de prison
hyper énervés ils pensent que je suis un
criminel que j'étais fier d'être un jeu
bien malin on peut on peut un peu on
peut comprendre
ouais mais je vais le lui non mais bien
sûr nommé pour vous vous savez que vous
êtes innocent mais pour lui vous êtes un
terroriste capturé des débits élevés de
32 personnes qui inquiets mais voilà qui
est l'auteur d'un attentat horrible vous
vous imaginez bien qui va pas faire de
cadeau à mais j'ai une scène avec le
sous-directeur là que j'oublierai jamais
j'avais quand il m'a retiré toutes les
affaires il m'a laissé le rasoir il m'a
déposé j'épouse jure qu'il avait posées
sur l'évier m'a dit ça je te l'est on
aura sûrement besoin
il m'a laissé conçu sortie 66 avec le
rasoir et j'ai dit jamais je n'oublierai
jeunes oublier ça et je vais pas vous
lâcher et il m'a dit oui bien sûr qu'est
ce que vous lui et moi je me sens rive 1
et à la fin ils ont tous baissé la tête
quand je sortait de prison l'an alors
j'aimerais revenir mais que si vous
aviez le directeur la prison illettré et
quand il vous disait quoi ils avaient
les nerfs sont moi c'est gênant magre
aucun privilège mais il va rester toute
ta vie ici tu vas mourir ici tu crois tu
vas voir un privilège mais alors rien du
tout je peux appeler au moins ma famille
non rien il m'a tout retirer c'est à la
fin après trois jours de détention il
m'a autorisé à appeler ma mère et quand
j'ai appelé ma mère a non là je tombais
embarras en larmes biens médicaux à
votre mère m'aime moi c'est pas moi mais
je sais que c'est pas toi je t'ai pas
éduqué comme ça mais votre mère est là
elle a douté on savait qu'il fallait
faire mais oui qu'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire là je vais attaquer est
inquiète et toi comment non mais elle me
dit mais comme moi je m'inquiète moi mr
dans l'état dans lequel ils sont et elle
s'inquiète pour moi bien sûr
et en fait je suis là évidente inquiète
nous va bien tout va bien un fait arrête
de mentir je sais que tout va pas bien
raconte-moi el-assad ça a duré quelques
minutes
moi j'ai pas pu terminer conversation
avec mais j'étais en larmes et j'étais
heureux d'avoir parlé
mr parce que tout ce que je voulais lui
dire mme hama c'est tout ce qu'on
raconte sur moi c'est cette info ça vous
a soulagé sa terrible alors comment
s'est terminée cette histoire alors la
prob là je regarde la télévision donc
leur cellule en train de regarder la
télé ouais d'abord il faut que tu as
fait une chose c'est que j'ai pas mangé
on m'a ramené un plat de spaghettis il
était bourré de crachats et envoyer les
crachats dessus alors oui mais qu'est ce
que vous ne sais quoi ça m'étonnera rien
d'autre
100 content que tu vas être bouffé tout
ça reste de ta vie j'aimais alors je
bouffe pas moi je rentrais en grève de
la faim et donc je reste en grève de la
faim je bouffe rien j'ai bu un peu dos
et tout sera enlevé il ya vait vous
savez on nous ramène des petits trucs de
nutella là je bouffais des petits trucs
comme ça juste pour que ça tienne un peu
c'est tout mais sinon j'avais rien
d'autre et je suis resté j'ai perdu 7
kilos quand je rentrais chez moi et je
découvre sur une chaîne de télévision
fayçal shifu et nazaire s'est libéré ça
je suis là en taule je me dis mais je
peux pas libéré si il faudrait porter
quoi donc je stocke ouais je demande
ouais je regarde à la télé ils disent
que je suis libéré
c'est un maton qui vient qui me dit
maintenant c'était fou toi tu es libre
tu vas rester toute ta vie ici je dis ok
sa voix est donc l'année souligné vous
avez pas montré à la télé disent que je
suis athée je suis libéré mais non non
c'est là toute ta vie tu vas jamais
sortir médias conneries la télévision et
là une leur plus tard itoc et me dit
prépare toi tu libéré faire [ __ ]
non tu vas te préparer la cellule et les
ouvre la porte
nettoie la cellule t libérez vous dites
nettoyer mais voilà j'ai rangé la
cellule grande île à 15
c'était la condition pour sortir son nom
skis monde il faut tout ranger faute
oublier que ce soit correcte et ensuite
vous allez attendre le repas c'est des
fous et tout ça et tu sera libéré j'ai
dû attendre leur page mais quand je
serai jugé pas cru je devrais des
données mois papier parce que je crois
pas en conneries là ils m'ont amené une
feuille et là je vois libre d'ailleurs
je n'ai ici avec moi voilà c'est le fax
juge d'instruction signées datées de
l'opération qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous êtes et vous avez été libéré alors
il faut savoir que quand j'étais libéré
ça a pris trois heures ils devaient me
libérer à 15 heures pour que c'est
important il devait me libérera 15
heures ils m'ont libéré à 18 heures donc
ils m'ont gardé trois heures en
détention
la russe qu'est ce qui se passe je
prends le taxi
et moi je vois plein de nains plate
journalistes mais je me dis tu démarres
continue on va chez ma mère et on voit
trois trois journalistes mais un peu
moins
donc je rentre chez l'un des rejetons
c'est là que je réalise en fait c'est
toute l'émotion est tombé sur moi mais
qui s'y passe et qu'est-ce qui a fait
que vous avez été libérés mais les
preuves ne sont pas conforté par l'anc
et c'est tout ce que je sais c'est
toucher ou fayçal a été remis en liberté
mais parce que les preuves n'ont pas été
confortée par l'enquêté donc moi même je
suis sur place de mai tu comprends pas
que vous avez vous avez dû être alors
oui plus mais la baie de tout soupçon
juste va il n'y a pas assez de preuves
donc nécessaire à sa guise ouais ah oui
donc n'ont pas été conforme toi donc en
sais pas où vous n'êtes pas et on savait
vous avez quand même que ça recommence à
huy ah ouais mais là ça recommence
écoles lendemain le lendemain à huy et
salons j'ai apprécié chez moi j'ai un
pote
elle est folle pour cette histoire c'est
une saga ont fait pour cette primaire et
vous êtes chez vous impossible de dormir
non c'est clair il ya les journalistes
vers la porte et en fait il embête ma
mère et je veux pas qu'ils en veux pas m
donc le lendemain que ce qui se passe
donc j'ai mon ami qui a été libéré aussi
qu'ils étaient avec moi dans la voiture
finalement on vient chez ma mère il me
dit écoute moi je te propose de venir
dans mon appartement
c'est un peu plus loin c'est en dehors
de bruxelles ce sera beaucoup plus calme
on démarre on marchait dans cet
appartement
le lendemain la police l'appel celle qui
nous arrêter pour lui demander de venir
récupérer son véhicule qui avait été
saisie le jour de l'arrestation
il y avait plein de trucs d'empreintes
dessus et c'est mon appart été saccagés
quand j'ai saccagé y avait des trucs
d'empreintes bref c'était une scène de
crime quoi donc ils l'appellent pour
aller chercher le véhicule
il va chercher le véhicule et il ferme
derrière moi donc il n'est dans
l'appartement et fait la connerie de
fermer quoi et il arrive au commissariat
et les garder lui parce qu' il dise donc
moi je vais aller étape par étape dont
kevin jonathan
deux heures plus tard il arrive pas et
j'entends des bruits dans la rue c'était
une rue très calme
je regarde par la fenêtre et je vois des
policiers en train de mettre des gilets
pare-balles des cagoules
non ah ouais security encore pour moi à
ce que c'est pour moi elles sont il ya
dix voitures la porte je fais ça et je
vois l'arsenal et je me dis sont venus
ponctuer ans et sont venus pour terminer
le travail
bon j'ai pas ramener comme ça j'ai eu un
comme on dit un réflexe j'ai vu le
balcon en fait j'ai vu une fenêtre
j'aime et je revis pas ça je veux pas
relancer
vous avez failli senti chez moi j'étais
sûr au deuxième étage j'ai vu le balcon
j'ai même si j'étais je sais pas ce qui
m'est arrivé j'ai eu peur c'est
l'instinct de survie chez page et je
voulais pas revivre ce à quoi donc j'ai
foncé et je trouve sur une plate forme
je me suis cassé puis je vous vois un
petit étang najjar d'un en fait et julia
l'hélicoptère qui survolait donc moi je
me dis faut que je me mets ton froid
pour pas que l'hélicoptère voit la
chaleur je suis là je rentre en genre de
défi de deux je fuis quoi je viens fuir
donc je vais dans l'eau je trouve une
petite couverture et je me cache en
dessous d'hélicoptères j'attends une é
kopter part je reste deux heures comme
ça jusqu'au moment où j'étais en it
porte et en hypothermie
donc je tremblais de partout et je
remonte quand là il y avait plus les
policiers après deux heures je suis
remonté dans l'appartement et l'alliage
voisin qui me voient qu'ils appellent
non pas la police antiterroriste qui est
venu le matin dans l'appartement mais
une police locale la police locale
débarque et ipte la porte avec un bélier
non mais moi je me cache dans le lit je
vais me cacher et quand il arrive
j'ai un truc une réaction je lui dis
mais pourquoi vous pointe avec quatre
armes et c'est des policiers en uniforme
il pointe et là je leur dis mais
pourquoi voulez me tuer pourquoi
hélas le même s'ils comprennent pas ils
disent non on est venu pour un
cambriolage penser que en fait le mec
est passé donc le voisin a signalé un
cambriolage
toutes les questions a fait ça là bien
entendu on passe à la dernière partie
merci mais ça fait sale c'est incroyable
votre histoire est donc après vous avez
été ils avaient tous au fond ils ont
trouvé le coupable
bien entendu de là vous étiez son
aileron oui jours plus tard
huit jours plus tard donc pendant huit
jours vous dites ça nous retombe et de
st pendant huit jours c'est moi là je
suis en panique j'essaie de comprendre
ce qui se passe est en fait je regarde
ce qui s'est dit dans la presse donc
et le jeu je vois mais fayçal shifu
radicaliser et il ya des amalgames qui
se faisait le truc c'est qu'après les
gens iraient ils vous disaient quoi vous
en votre endroit que même les
journalistes et personnes et que c'était
vrai
son digne et loyal terroristes la
majorité de ma famille non mais j'espère
qu'il a rien à voir
parce que là on a le même nom de famille
et ma santé ma mère
demandé de garder une distance tant
qu'ils restent inculpés en fait c'est ça
quand je suis libéré l'épreuve n'ont pas
été confortée par l' enquête
et en plus ils restent inculpés et les
médias ont joué là dessus certains
médias ont joué comment ça se fait que
fayçal chiffon et libéré le troisième
terroriste qui a été inculpé etc mais
reste inculpé des trois chefs
d'inculpation les plus graves de
belgique etc et les mêmes chefs
d'inculpation que le véritable
terroriste du coup je suis là terminé
ses ouailles à quoi sert ni quand mais
pardon j'ai une question est donc vous
quittez vous même en taxi alors que vous
faites la une de tous les journaux
et qu'est ce qui se passe vous vous
enfermez vous avez peur parce qu'il ya
des gens qui peuvent avoir envie de se
venger sur route je vais dans ma boîte
aux lettres justement deux menaces de
mort écrites et vous n'avez pas de
protection vous ai rien rien du tout au
contraire non j'ai j'ai plutôt je vois
des policiers qui me suit en fait est
vraiment des policiers ils ont tous des
capuches il matos des capuches et quand
il se retourne je vois l'oreillette
donc moi je paniquais suis dit qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire la passe qui si je
peux conclure sont de 1,1 simon fait ça
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire après et
donc j'ai appelé le juge d'instruction
qui m'a libéré je les remercie patrick
de koster je les remercie pour votre que
vous avez été est-ce que vous avez été
dédommagés à n'ont jusqu'à présent dont
0 mais je viens en fait de s'attraper
cinq ans le 5 janvier
j'ai reçu des excuses officielles de la
justice est une bien avant alors ils
m'ont dit clairement on vous considère
comme aussi à une des victimes des
attentats de bruxelles
quand on m'a dit ça et qu'on m'a dit que
j'étais c'était pas moi quoi c'est comme
si on m'avait retiré un sac de 200 kg de
mes épaules cinq ans j'ai dû me balader
avec ça ou dans la leurs mules l'homme
au chapeau c'était en fait
mohamed abrines mais voilà il a été
arrêté huit jours après quand on met
annoncé mais je m'en foutais je sais que
c'est pas moi c'est ouais c'est lui et
vous avez pu vous reconstruire très vite
ou bien c'est un mensonge et du pendant
cinq ans j'ai été arrêté à plusieurs
reprises par la police
donc j'ai été soupçonné une fois à tort
accusé par dont une fois tort mais après
on est revenu en 2017 pour une
perquisition à deux heures du matin manu
militari
ils sont rentrés par les fenêtres
j'habite dans un grenier il faut
s'imaginer comment ça se passe il peut
que les revenus pourquoi alors ils sont
venus pour mac donc c'était une autre
accusation attentes menaces d'attentats
dans une salle de concert vers belgique
pourquoi vous la police dit nous
viol intime conviction qui lui
ressemblait à la personne qui a fait
cette menace d'attentats possibles donc
ça mec qui passe par là et qui crie ça
va exploser il faut faire une peinture
un peu changé de mains ce qu'a fait le
look de nogent semblerait que la
personne non mais je vous donne un
conseil c'est un truc de fou
mais sait on dirait qu'ils avaient le
poster non poster au commissariat et qui
pensaient que moi en fait et ça c'est la
vision de l'histoire de fées salé et
votre famille est là elle a dû vraiment
souffrir bat mais en fait c'est surtout
les mots clés rimok mais rires moqueurs
de tout le monde doit mettre son fils
peu patraque comment ça se fait qu'il
ait eu à gérer mais qu'il reste inculpé
c'est pas possible
la police n'a pas échappé à ce niveau là
et puis à plusieurs reprises et puis la
presse joue sur sa source attendait
cette suspicion c'est pas normal et donc
en fait on passe le temps ma famille
passe son temps à dire non et ils
doivent répéter l'histoire
et ben c'est que vous allez avoir
réparation que vous allez toucher un
dédommagement pas du tout j'ai même pas
cru que j'allais recevoir des excuses et
logement le jour on me l'a dit ça m'a
vraiment fait très bien car ça m'a fait
beaucoup de bien
donc j'espère mais ça rachètera jamais
le choc émotionnel que j'ai subi le choc
post traumatique jeu jean legendre pas
encore aujourd'hui